manifestement il y a eu accord entre le
Hamas et le gouvernement israélien
conclut cette nuit 50 otage israéliens
don des binationaux j'espère j'espère
des Français on ne sait pas au moment où
on se parle je crois qu'on le SAA que
demain matin à la première heure quand
tu auras vraiment la libération mais 50
Otages israéliens parfois des
binationaux seront libérés en échange
d'une trêve de de 4 jours permettant par
exemple l'arrivée de 100 camions
humanitaires sur la bande de Gaza donc
c'est une bonne nouvelle prenons-la
comme cela même si nous savons que les
drames ne sont pas encore totalement
terminés non une pause de 4 jours le
gouvernement français espère que cette
pause et bien qui ouvre aussi qui permet
la libération des otages elle puisse
mener à une trêve humanitaire durable
c'est ce qu'a dit ce matin Catherine
Colona c'est une vraie étape où est-ce
qu'il faut être beaucoup plus prudent
que ça c'est une première étape mais une
vraie étapeemtori vous pensez dans ce
qui se joue en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que la guerre est terrible
depuis le 7 octobre donc depuis 7
semaines avec une réponse extrêmement
forte on le sait bien puissante de la
part d'Israël en réplique au drame qui
s'est passé le 7 octobre vous savez hier
j'étais à la séance qu'ù on a projeté le
film du 7 et du 8 octobre j'ai vu des
scènes absolument indécibles qui ont été
présentés donc aujourd'hui espérons que
cette période intense de guerre soit non
pas derrière nous parce que je pense que
israël veut éradiquer le Hamas ça reste
le but
en la matière mais que les populations
civiles arrêtent de souffrir comme elle
souffrent aujourd'hui Roger kucci qui
nous a annoncé que des parlementaires
vont se rendre en Israël et le président
du Sénat également qui devrait se rendre
en Israël ainsi que dans les territoires
palestiniens vous avez vous êtes au
courant de cette initiative vous allez
je ser je serai présent dans ce voyage
effectivement prévu fin décembre
qu'est-ce qui est à la manœuvre c'est le
groupe d'amitié France Israël c'est
interparlementairire et le président
Larcher et le président Larcher je je
pense que là ce sera réservé d'abord au
sénateur d'accord de l'annoncer en tant
que tel et moi je suis très heureux de
de m'associer j'ai été plusieurs fois
sollicité par le CRIF pour y aller et
son agenda ne l'ont pas permis mais je
savais que le président de l'arché
prrait prendrait cette initiative comme
il l'avait fait
d'ailleurs pour Kief en voyage donc avec
lui juste après les l'invasion russe
j'ai une dernière question on vous a vu
réuni sénateur dans le Peron central ce
midi avec des photos des personnes qui
sont toujours a Tage quelle est l'idée
de cette initiative on a vu que la même
chose avait eu lieu chez les députés
c'est de par Rainer une personne qui est
toujours disport disparu oui moi
moi-même je je
parinene un travailleur thaïlandais qui
est aujourd'hui dans les jaules ou dans
les tunnels de Gaza du Hamas c'est un
symbole parce que nous savons bien que
c'est pas nous qui allons faire libérer
ces otages mais quelque part il y a une
forme d'humanité qui transpire par cette
démarche et j'en suis très heureux et
très heureux y participer la cause des
otages elle est trop oubliée dans
l'opinion dans les médias vous le pensez
vous savez la prise d'otage c'est un
crime de guerre le ramas a commis un
crime de guerre y compris vis-à-vis de
bébé de de quelques mois vous imaginez
cela
donc cela est absolument indigne
insupportable et c'est bien que par des
initiatives telles que celles que nous
avons pris ici au Sénat nous puissions
rappeler que il y a des hommes des
femmes des enfants qui aujourd'hui
souffrent dans les tunnels de du ramas à
Gaza